[Music]
i was a drug dealer
and i got incarcerated
when i came out i was like there's no
way i'm gonna get a second chance or get
a job
i'm trying to achieve and running is
part of my way of getting there
this great big story was made possible
by
dignity health hello human kindness
[Music]
my name is manuel navarro and i am a
runner with back of my feet
back on my feet is an organization that
helps people fight homelessness
and at this point in my life the lowest
point of my life that's where i'm at and
it's helping me be successful and
achieve everything i want to achieve the
right way
my name is pete roller and i'm a
volunteer and board member with back of
my feet
manny and i have been running together
for nine months we run three mornings a
week at 5 45 in the morning
back my feet is a national nonprofit
that works with individuals who are
experiencing homelessness or in some
stage of recovery and provides a hand up
to employment and housing and
independence through community and
fitness
[Music]
running is a really nice complement to
the recovery for many of our members
running in particular provides the
physical release for a lot of us we're
replacing
negativity
those three mornings a week or the three
mornings where they know they can come
and be supported by the rest of the
group and really feel good about
themselves because whatever comes in
between that is going to be much harder
and back on my feet provides the link
for them to successfully continue that
recovery i know it works because the
changes in the individuals members
volunteers myself are visible and
they're tangible for our members it
allows them to feel human again and i've
seen countless members just blossom
when they come to the morning circle
they're just another runner
[Applause]
i hated running but now i love running i
mean just the community they make you
feel very welcome they're really there
to help you to embrace you and to
support the fact that you're trying to
be successful in life and trying to do
something right and the connection that
me and pete have is
amazing i never had real friends before
in the drug business you don't trust
anybody and here i am trusting he's
always telling me
how i could do better and pushing me to
do better and that's good because he's
there to support me and i think we all
deserve a second chance and i'm taking
it